now to Washington where Republicans take
control of the house today for the first
time in four years but first they need
to pick a speaker leader Kevin McCarthy
struggled to win over some right-wing
colleagues is the latest front in the
battle for the future of the GOP Scott
McFarland is on Capitol Hill Scott good
morning good morning a busy day here at
the U.S Capitol but really nothing can
happen until the newly elected members
of the U.S House select a speaker and
this morning there is 11th Hour Intrigue
and uncertainty over how that boat's
going to play out and how long it's
going to take
the motion is adopted
it's the job house Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy of California has sought
for years to be the next Speaker of the
House second in line behind the vice
president to the White House and the
person expected to lead Republicans
Nationwide in challenging President
Biden's agenda
but this morning he's still scrambling
to Wrangle enough votes to win the
position a block of the more
conservative Freedom caucus members have
pledged not to vote for McCarthy there's
nothing about Kevin McCarthy that
indicates that he will bring the change
that's needed to Washington or that's
needed to the Congress Mick Mulvaney was
serving in the U.S House 10 years ago
when he joined a faction that tried to
block his party's choice for Speaker of
the House Mulvaney says such efforts
often fall apart in the last minute it
is a really tough vote it's going to be
very pressure packed a lot of attention
it's not policy it's a really personal
sort of vote and people take it very
personally plus you're going against
your own party McCarthy who if speaker
would help decide which legislation gets
priority and which parts of the Biden
Administration would go under the
microscope first has already made
concessions trying to seek the final
elusive votes including making it easier
for colleagues to oust him if they're
displeased with his performance but it
could come at a cost you essentially cut
yourself off at your knees on on being
the speaker that you don't have the the
authority and the ability and the power
that you you that goes with the office
if you give all that stuff away as part
of a negotiation
today also marks the exit of Nancy
Pelosi as U.S House speaker the first
and only woman to ever hold that
position Pelosi will be sworn in today
as a rank and file member of the House
representing San Francisco by whoever is
the next U.S House speaker
drama on the hill will be watching Scott
thank you very much